Stellen Sie sich vor,
nach einem Cyberangriff gibt es ein
breitflächiges Blackout. Es funktioniert kein
Handynetz mehr,
die Supermärkte werden ausgeraubt, Sie
hören Schüsse, auf den Straßen herrscht
das Recht des Stärkeren.
Ein zweites Szenario: Terroristen mit
Kampferfahrung aus Krisengebieten,
bewaffnet mit Maschinengewehren,
Panzerfäusten und Granatwerfern, bedrohen
das Leben der ÖsterreicherInnen. Es sollen
möglichst viele Tote und Schwerverletzte
produziert werden. Die kritische
Infrastruktur, Staudämme, Flughäfen und
dergleichen sind bedroht. Sie glauben
jetzt sicher, das Österreichische
Bundesheer schützt Sie in derartigen
Situationen. Ich muss Sie leider enttäuschen.
Aufgrund der drastischen Sparmaßnahmen
der letzten 30 Jahre können wir das
nicht mehr ausreichend gewährleisten.
Im vorliegenden Bericht erfahren Sie
mehr Details. Was sind die Bedrohungen?
Was braucht es, um Sie zu schützen? Welche
Investitionen sind notwendig, und wie
schaut ein gangbarer Weg in das Jahr 2030 aus, damit Ihr Schutz und Ihre
Sicherheit wieder durch das
Österreichische Bundesheer gewährleistet ist.